bonjour claude luche maison l'édito de
la matinale ce matin sur cette visite
historique du pape en irak est ce que
c'est une main tendue selon vous aux
musulmans écoutez je crois que cette
visite a une grande signification à la
fois apostolique évidemment coulé pour
les chrétiens d'orient le soutien aux
chrétiens d'orient
vous n'êtes pas un seul ne radie le pas
mais c'est aussi une visite au cul
munich est en effet une main tendue au
dos une main tendue à l'islam
et cette rencontre tout à fait
extraordinaire avec le grand ayatollah
ali al-sistani dans la vie la dja qui a
marqué les esprits
ces images sont très fortes et je crois
par cette visite le pape a fait preuve
d'un grand courage un courage physique
d'abord parce que c'était dangereux et
que beaucoup de personnes lui avaient
déconseillé de faire cette visite
maintenant et avait suggéré le report
mais aussi parce que tout le monde n'est
pas d'accord au sein de l'église
catholique et au vatican sur l'or
l'engagement d'un tel dialogue avec
l'islam et je crois qu'il a eu le
courage de passer outre ces objections
parce qu'il pensait que c'était cela
qu'il fallait faire en ce moment
et en effet les trois jours de sa visite
semble avoir donné raison puisque tout
s'est très bien passé sans aucun
incident et que le gouvernement irakien
a bien entendu est très très content de
la manière dont tout cela s'est passé
des mesures de sécurité ont été
efficaces et on voit bien que les autres
pays également surtout obliger de
de rendre hommage à l'initiative prise
par parle pas et que le dimanche prison
cette rencontre avec qu'elle allait
l'ayatollah sistani
c'est le temps fort de la visite du pape
oui bien sûr enfin c'est le temps fort
avec aussi le soutien apporté à l'église
chrétienne d'orient
les images fortes sont aussi le pape
célébrant la messe au milieu de débris
qui avaient été détruites qui avait été
bombardé par l'état islamique
mais s'agissant de la rencontre avec
l'ayatollah halal si c'est lui je crois
que c'est très important parce que c'est
l'autorité religieuse la plus importante
du chiisme à l'heure actuelle après la
disparition de l'ayatollah khomeini il
lui même se présente comme un ascète qui
vit dans des conditions extrêmement
modeste ce qui n'est pas pour déplaire
sans doute au pape françois il a su dans
une pièce dépourvu de tout ce décorum
il était assis sur des banquettes en
plastique séparé simplement par une une
table basse pas de fleurs pote
décoration et je crois que l'ayatollah
sistani
il respecte très strictement les
préceptes de sa religion en se levant la
nuit pour faire les prières qui l'est
qui sont qui sont prescrits alors sur le
plan politique il appartient à une
branche du chiisme qui prône le retrait
par rapport à la politique c'est à dire
qu'il n'est pas sur le devant de la
scène
contrairement à ce qui se passe en iran
est d'ailleurs originaire d'iran
lui-même mais il a joué un rôle
important en irak il ya toujours soutenu
l'indépendance de l'irak à l'époque de
saddam hussein il était en résidence
surveillée donc qu'il n'était pas en
odeur de sainteté si je puis dire
et ensuite
pendant l'invasion américaine il a joué
un rôle important dans le sens du
dialogue
il a toujours été un homme de dialogue
et d'ailleurs dans la déclaration qu'il
a qu'il a fait après la visite du pape
il a très clairement dit que bien
entendu les chrétiens avaient toute leur
place devaient avoir leur place en irak
est là et il est le promoteur du
dialogue interreligieux que le pape
lui-même et ses essais de d'instaurer
notamment entre entre l'islam et est là
et les religions et les religions
chrétiennes alors c'est compliqué parce
que on y lira qui est une terre qui est
compliqué sur plan politique mais aussi
sur plan religieux
les chrétiens d'orient sont eux mêmes
très divisés en différentes églises les
chaldéens des syriaques qu'ils auront
toute leur propre autorité religieuse
mais qui reconnaisse toute l'autorité du
pape et c'est aussi cela qu'il est venu
faire pour montrer cette unité le
religieuse qui aujourd'hui doit se
considérer comme une force de paix donc
il a voulu faire un voyage de son temps
le dialogue la paix et je pense qu'il en
restera il restera quelques grâces
justement la diplomatie du vatican at
elle une influence ou en tout cas on va
jouer dans la région claude c'est une
diplomatie c'est efficace d'abord c'est
une vraie diplomatie puisqu'ils au
vatican une académie diplomatique et qu'
un certain nombre de deux de ses
diplômés se consacre à la diplomatie
c'est à dire qu'ensuite ils vont dans
les nonciatures il y a une ambassade du
vatican à bagdad avec un bec annonce à
sa tête qui d'ailleurs pour la petite
histoire avait apparemment été
diagnostiqué positif au test du que lui
de 10,9 et qui donc a dû se tenir à
l'écart de la visite du pape
françois mais cette visite a été
évidemment est manifestement très bien
préparés et très bien préparé par les
canaux de la diplomatie vaticane des
envoyés spéciaux qui ont négocié pendant
six mois
la rencontre avec l'ayatollah sistani et
puis probablement des contacts aussi
avec diverses forces du pays pour que
les choses se passent bien et dans la
mesure du possible pour éviter tous les
incidents et la diplomatie vaticane
traditionnellement est une des mieux
informés du monde parce que elle
bénéficie aussi des réseaux qui sont les
siens à travers les nonciatures mais
aussi à travers les grilles ce qu'est
l'église catholique et à travers les
prêtres eux-mêmes
par conséquent le pape a fella de la
démonstration de la capacité de cette
diplomatie vaticane
après pareille visite aussi dangereuse
est aussi difficile que celle là et puis
montraient qu'il y avait peut-être
d'autres voies que la guerre d'autres
voies que les bombardements que les
missiles et que le dialogue pourrait
aussi porter ses fruits
merci beaucoup claude blanche maison
c'était l'édito de la matinale on vous
retrouve tous les mardis matin pour cet
édito je le rappelle vous êtes expert en
relations internationales